>> Laura: A POLICY PROFESSOR
IS BLAMING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FOR CRIME IN
MEXICO.
YES, YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT.
GUADALUPE JOINS US NOW TO
EXPLAIN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
DO YOU THINK IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED BACK TO MEXICO WERE
ALREADY COMMITTING CRIMES BEFORE
THEY WERE DEPORTED BACK TO
MEXICO?
BECAUSE YOU WERE SAYING
DEPORTATION POLICY IS MAKING
MEXICO'S LIFE WORSE.
EXPLAIN.
>> MEXICO AND THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE VERY
VULNERABLE.
WE HAVE CARTELS AT THE BORDER,
OPERATING AT THE BORDER.
WE HAVE CORRUPTION IN MEXICO,
THEREFORE, WHEN YOU DEPORT
PEOPLE TO THE BORDER, THEY FIND
THEMSELVES LIKE THEY WANT TO
COME BACK TO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR FAMILIES
AND SOME OF THEM ARE FORCED TO
PARTICIPATE IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES, OR SOME OF THEM WANT
TO GO TO THE UNITED STATES SO
THEY HIRED SOME SMUGGLERS THAT
ARE IN AN ACTION WITH THE
CARTEL.
>> Laura: I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WHY IS THAT OUR PROBLEM?
>> WELL, IT'S NOT YOUR PROBLEM
BUT YOU MIGHT HAVE A PROBLEM, AS
WELL.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE MORE CRIMINAL
GROUPS OPERATING ON THE SIDE OF
THE MEXICO BORDER.
AS YOU KNOW, PEOPLE ARE STILL
ARRIVING IN THE UNITED STATES NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE ANY BORDERS, REALLY?
WHY HAVE A BORDER AT THIS POINT?
WHY NOT MAKE IT ALL ONE MEXICO
AND UNITED STATES AND THE CARTEL
WILL KIND OF GO OUT OF BUSINESS?
WE WILL BE ALL ONE COUNTRY.
>> I BELIEVE ANY COUNTRY HAS TO
HAVE SOME KIND OF LIMITS, AND I
THINK BORDERS ARE IMPORTANT TO
HAVE LIMITS.
>> Laura: BUT IF YOU CAN HAVE
A BORDER, PRESUMABLY WHEN PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE PERMISSION TO BE
HERE, THEN THEY CAN BE SENT
HOME.
EVERY COUNTRY ON THE FACE OF THE
PLANET SEND PEOPLE HOME WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE PERMISSION, AND
ESPECIALLY IF THEY HAVE
COMMITTED A CRIME.
THEN YOU'RE REALLY SUBJECTING
THEM TO DEPORTATION.
I THINK AMERICANS DON'T FEEL
LIKE IT'S THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAKE SURE -- WE WANT MEXICO
TO BE WELL, BUT WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO CROSS THE BORDER.
IT REAL QUICK.
>> I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT BUT AT